[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 149 of the weekly
"Google Cloud Platform" podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm
here with my colleague
almost always, Melanie Warrick.
How are you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Mark.
I'm good.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing all right.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, we are back
from Strange Loop this week.
At least for a
minute, we're together
in San Francisco, which is good.
MARK MANDEL: Lovely.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And this week, we're
going to be sharing
another episode from some
of the episodes I gathered
while I was in South
Africa a couple weeks back.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
specifically for episode 149,
we have with us this
week Yabebal and Jessica,
who are both researchers
from the AIMS Research Group,
based in South Africa.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: So looking
forward to hearing from them
and talking to them about some
of the research they're doing
and other organizations
that are in the area.
But before we get
into that, we'll
always do like we do-- the
cool things of the week,
and we will end with a
question of the week.
And so for this
week our question,
as always, coming from Mark,
if I'm using the cluster
autoscaler for
Kubernetes or GKE,
how can I prevent it from
removing specific nodes
from the cluster
when scaling down?
MARK MANDEL: I have an answer.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
glad you have an answer.
MARK MANDEL: I do.
MELANIE WARRICK: You always--
you have all the answers.
MARK MANDEL: Not
all the answers.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Some of the answers.
MARK MANDEL: I have some
of the Kubernetes answers.
MELANIE WARRICK: Or you make
it sound like you have--
no, it's good.
It's all good.
All right, well,
Mark, let's talk
about cool things of the week.
And we've got one at the top
that's, of course, down your--
MARK MANDEL: It's
about Kubernetes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--expertise alley.
MARK MANDEL: It is, it's true.
I actually really
like this blog post
on the Google Cloud blog
called "A Kubernetes
FAQ for the C-suite."
So basically, for
CxO top-level, or I
think even people who aren't
necessarily technically
oriented, maybe like not
engineers, that kind of stuff,
but want to understand
what Kubernetes
and what benefits it gives.
And it has a really
nice breakdown
of, like, what is Kubernetes,
why does Kubernetes
matter, why does IT like
Kubernetes so much, what
are the main benefits, et
cetera, et cetera, how do I get
started, that kind of stuff.
And it has some technical as
well as non-technical answers,
as well as different
perspectives
that may help you explain
it to people who sit maybe
at a C level, or a business
level, or that kind of stuff.
I actually really like it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Do
we have any C-suites
out there listening to us?
MARK MANDEL: I hope so.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know
that's not our target,
but yes, we probably have a
mixture of people out there.
Anyway, so let me
go ahead and talk
about a blog post about
BigQuery and surrogate keys.
So this is a how to set up a
surrogate key in your BigQuery.
And this is a nice
practical approach
that Marco Tranquilin
had put together.
And he talks about how
you can generate it.
You could do something
where you're,
like, hashing the row number.
There's some
alternative approaches
he has around actually
hash of the record fields
and using the result
as a surrogate key.
So he gives you a step-through
on how you can do that.
And we'll include that
link in the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Coming up next, there's
also a great article
from the serverless
compute team talking
about adding custom intelligence
to Gmail with serverless
on GCP.
Basically, it's a
really nice how-to
on how to build your
own intelligence
into your own
Gmail capabilities.
So if you've ever wanted to do
your own custom actions based
on, say, a particular email
coming in, or a set of email,
or a content inside an
email, or basically anything,
really, it gives you
basically pretty much
all the code that you need to
do to do that and set that up
for yourself.
So if you ever wanted to
automate yourself out of a job,
or maybe into a job,
this might be for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know you want
to take it to the next level.
I actually did try
automating something way back
in the day with my Gmail.
So it's nice to see that there's
some more established tools
that you can use versus trying
to write it from scratch.
You should try that.
You should check it out.
All right, well, the other
thing we wanted to mention
is they are announcing
Google Cloud Tasks.
It's a task queues service
for App Engine Flex and Second
Generation runtime.
So this is basically a
centralized cloud task
API that's fully
managed asynchronous.
It allows you to, in essence,
do task execution service
for any application running
anywhere using a standard API.
So it's great for task queues.
And they talk through
that a little bit,
and help you understand what
that means, what that looks
like for App Engine, especially
considering if you were
using task queues in the past.
Apparently, this is
really all the stuff
you would do with task queue
you will do with Cloud Tasks.
So you can check that out.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Worth noting, like, existing
App Engine customers
can continue to manage their
tasks via the App Engine SDK.
It's also going to work.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's good.
All right, I think we wanted
to give one last mention, which
is sort of related to
something we touched on back
when we talked to Jeff Dean
a couple weeks back ago.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so Unity and DeepMind
have announced a partnership
to advance AI research.
It'll basically enable
DeepMind to develop
a lot of virtual
environments and tasks,
basically for doing
a lot of AI research.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
So the whole virtual
environments,
we had touched on that with him
a little bit about how that's
one of the values coming
out of the AI space,
is seeing these
virtual environments
for being able to experiment in.
So you should check this out
and see what they're up to.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Awesome.
Melanie, why don't we go
have a chat with our friends
over in South Africa?
MELANIE WARRICK: Sounds good.
I'm happy to have with us today
Yabebal Fantaye and Jessica
Phalafala.
Thank you both for joining.
JESSICA PHALAFALA:
Thank you for having us.
YABEBAL FANTAYE: Thank
you for having us.
MELANIE WARRICK: So Yabebal,
why don't we start with you?
Can you tell us about who
you are and your background?
YABEBAL FANTAYE: So yeah,
I'm Yabebal Fantaye,
and I grew up in
Ethiopia, Addis Ababa,
and I did my undergraduate
studies in Addis Ababa.
And then I went to Cape Town
for my Master's, and then I
went to Italy for my PhD.
And then did some
post-docs in Europe
and came back now to Africa
with something called the Robert
Bosch Foundation.
They funded this research
here called ARETÉ AIMS Chair,
which is really unusual funding
because it allows you to work
anywhere in Africa.
And so I am really
enjoying being
now Pan-African, practically,
not just talking about it.
So I am doing research in
areas of cosmology, which
is my main speciality, and
also using satellite images
to try to understand-- is Africa
going in the right direction,
and can we get that not only
in the official statistics,
but also through some mining the
data, which is available free,
satellite images.
So those are kind of
background, I would say.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
And I know when we were talking
before you were telling me
about some of the
travels that you
do for work, which is
wonderful that you get
to call yourself Pan-African.
YABEBAL FANTAYE: I think
now I can call it like that,
and it's really different.
When you are really doing it,
it's actually much different,
because you really start
seeing the similarities.
And I think I'm now not
just philosophically only,
but practically, it is Africa
just as one makes sense.
That was probably the reason
why people in the 1960s,
you know, when they were
talking about Pan-Africanism,
they actually probably
felt similar in a way.
We share a lot more similarities
than our differences.
And our differences
just within Ethiopia,
we have so much difference
within different tribes
than probably I have with
other African countries.
So in a way, you know, it's
just natural, that difference.
It's our beauty.
And we should just celebrate it.
But at the same time,
our similarities
are a lot, which we
can capitalize on that.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
And then, Jessica, can you
tell us a little bit about you?
JESSICA PHALAFALA: OK.
Thank you, Melanie.
I was born in Polokwane
here in South Africa.
And in terms of my studies,
I did my undergraduate
at Wits University.
And that was in economics
and mathematics.
I went on to do my post-grad to
Master's level at Wits as well.
And my specialization was
in functional analysis.
So I'm actually a
pure mathematician.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, wow.
JESSICA PHALAFALA: Yeah.
And so during my
master's, I realized
that I would like to
use the skills that I
attained to work towards a
PhD that's a little bit more
applied.
And that's when I
explored data science.
And then I moved to
the African Institute
for Mathematical
Sciences, and now I'm
doing my PhD in
applied mathematics.
And the area of my research
is Manifold Learning
and Approximation Theory.
So it does allow me to
use those functional
analysis and harmonic
analysis skills together
with some new skills, like
information theory and coding.
So it's been really a
wonderful experience.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
And so the Africa Institute
for Mathematical Science,
I know both of you are there.
Can you tell me a little bit
more, tell us a little bit more
about what the institution
focuses on in terms
of the research that it does?
YABEBAL FANTAYE: Yeah.
So the African Institute
of Mathematical Science,
usually just AIMS, was
founded in 2003 by Neil Turok.
And I think the main
idea was, of course,
Neil Turok got those ideas
when he was traveling,
that he was inspired by how
people think differently
in Africa.
And he believed that
their way of thinking,
the mathematical sciences,
should be the core.
And that's where I
think his vision was
like, OK, let's have
everywhere in Africa,
not just in South
Africa or localized,
but just everywhere
in Africa, let's have
like these examples that could
do in any of the mathematics,
physics or mathematics
or economics,
any of them which involves
some mathematical thinking,
to be leaders, and to try
and to be the first kind of--
an example for others to follow.
So I think it
worked phenomenally.
And that's why we're still here.
And since even-- like it
was in South Africa only,
but then it expanded now to
six other countries in Africa.
And it's graduating, I
think, more than 1,500 people
and from all over Africa.
According to the map that
you see everywhere in Africa
is green, which means
we have graduates
from everywhere in Africa.
And that is really great.
And then the research
aspect came around 2007.
It was started in South
Africa, the AIMS South Africa.
So that one involved lots
of researchers coming, some
of them just they are
temporally, some of them
are research scientists
there, but maybe affiliated
to other universities, for
example Stellenbosch, and also
University of Cape Town.
So the kind of work
we do, I would say,
like are financial
mathematics researchers,
there are biomathematics,
and there is cosmology,
which I am part of, but
which also now evolves
into the machine learning group.
And also now the data science
group that Jessica is in.
There are a lot more
coming and going also,
which I probably may not cover.
But every of the mathematical
science, I would say,
is covered.
And what makes AIMS special
is that actually there
are no lectures, per se.
So it's not like a very
different, intensive, one-year,
but a lot more introducing
people from everywhere
in the world who are really
doing amazing research.
They come and teach there
willingly, voluntarily.
And they basically
leave with the students
in the three-weeks module.
And they instruct, and
basically just the students
learn not only the subject,
but the way of thinking, right?
So which makes AIMS, I
would say, very special.
And then AIMS evolved into the
whole Next Einstein Initiative,
which is now centered
in Rwanda, and which
is managing not
only AIMS but also
there is the Next
Einstein Forum,
which every two years brings
together scientists, business
people, politicians in one.
And this is the
first of its kind.
There was no such big
gathering in Africa.
And that's really where you see
I am a Next Einstein Fellow.
And it highlights young people
doing something in research.
And if they are excellent
in their research,
they bring them together,
and then they highlight.
They give them that opportunity
to expose to media and others.
So AIMS and the Next
Einstein Initiative
is doing really amazing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Oh, please.
JESSICA PHALAFALA: I don't
know if you would also
like a student's
perspective, as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, I would
like a student's perspective.
JESSICA PHALAFALA: I would
say the one thing that really
stands out about AIMS is that
it's research and learning
intensive.
I was at a university
for seven years,
and the moment I
stepped into AIMS,
I can just feel the difference.
It's a collaborative
environment.
Like you said, you
have researchers
coming from across the world.
And it gives you an opportunity
to network and interact
with people who are like-minded,
who can maybe share ideas
on the work that you're doing.
And also, it exposes
you to people
outside of the country that
are working in your area.
And especially when you are
exploring a new area like I am,
AIMS has given me
the opportunity
to do research visits in
Berlin and visit a team that's
working that has
experts in this field,
so that I'm exposed
to that, and I'm
able to bring back those skills.
I think that's just the one
thing that really stands out
for me is that it's a
collaborative environment.
It's an intensive
research-intensive environment.
And I think that makes it
different to the university
setup.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's wonderful.
And you had mentioned
about in Berlin--
what other additional
collaborations are
done between AIMS
and other groups
that you haven't
already touched on?
How does AIMS participate
with other groups that
are within Africa,
as well as outside?
YABEBAL FANTAYE:
There again, AIMS
is not-- so it gives
degrees, but it's actual
affiliated to
Stellenbosch University.
So most of the
students do projects
in Stellenbosch University,
University of Cape Town,
Wits, other places.
So basically, it is not like--
it's an academic institute
but with wide-open door
for every collaboration
with different universities
within South Africa.
And that is AIMS, South Africa.
If it's AIMS, Ghana, it
would be like with all
the other universities locally.
As well as,
internationally, people
would come to have some
research visits, grants
that people come and just
stay there for a month
to do some of their research,
and as Jessica was saying,
to collaborate.
That's where you
meet a lot of people,
not only just the people
from outside Africa,
but also from inside Africa.
They come to teach.
They come to research visit.
And so those pursue
those affiliations
to get those networks.
So there's a lot
of this networking
being done within Africa, as
well as also outside Africa.
MELANIE WARRICK: Externally.
And it's based on each
person's-- the work that
they're doing, and how that
relates to other groups,
as well.
What additional
groups do you work
with in terms of the
research that you're doing?
YABEBAL FANTAYE: So for example,
the cosmology group at AIMS,
they have collaboration
with SKA, which
is the Square Kilometer Array.
This is the biggest radio
telescope being built.
And we have the data
science group there,
and the data science group,
and the cosmology group at AIMS
are collaborating.
We work on similar projects.
And also every group has
also their own collaboration
that they bring together.
For example, I have
collaboration in Munich,
and have collaboration
in Rome, and Oslo.
Which I basically-- through
that I bring visitors,
and I also go and visit.
So it's the same, I think,
as Jessica was saying,
there is a lot of these
collaborations going on.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Sharing of knowledge.
This is great.
And Jessica, you had
mentioned you were at Wits.
What is Wits?
JESSICA PHALAFALA:
So the full name
is the University of
the Witwatersrand.
It's in Johannesburg.
And it's one of our oldest
universities in South Africa
and ranked the top
in South Africa.
I did my undergrad
through to my master's.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's good to know.
I mean, I know most
universities do research.
Do they have a very
established research program
as well, affiliations
with other groups as well?
Because it sounds
like there's work
that's being done with
AIMS between Wits.
And I've heard of
it many times now.
JESSICA PHALAFALA: Yes,
so I think this is--
I don't know about
in other fields,
I think data science are
more informed, because that's
where it directly affects me.
We have a German research
chair at AIMS who's actually
working with some of
the supervisors at Wits,
and they are trying
to also create
a community of data scientists
who can collaborate together.
So one example of
this is there's
a four-year course called the
Theoretical Foundations of Data
Science that was started by the
former vice chancellor of Wits,
and Bubacarr Bah,
who is at AIMS.
And what they are doing is
taking staff members who
have master's degrees
and introducing them
to data science so that they
can explore it for their PhD.
So just initiatives like
that are taking place.
So I do think that
it is taking part
in creating programs for data
science and other research
areas.
That's just one example.
I'm sure there are many.
YABEBAL FANTAYE:
Physics sector, as well.
They have very strong particle
physics research group,
string theory, they're
very well known.
So there are many
of these research
groups that are strong at Wits.
MELANIE WARRICK: And it's
very well established.
I know another group
that I've heard
of talk a little bit
about this is CSIR.
Can you tell us a little bit
about CSIR, that you know of?
YABEBAL FANTAYE: Yes,
the only thing I know
is that they are involved
in many sectors of research.
So for example, I
know them through--
they manage, as far as I know,
the center for high performance
computing, which is
based in Cape Town.
This is going to be
also the one machine
that SK is going to
be using, because they
have the experience, as well
as just the machines to do it.
And my master's student has
been, for example, using that
just for his own research.
So they provide the
high-performance computing
platform.
And so they are involved in
many, many other research.
For example, we got
our satellite data
from the SANSA, which is
the National Space Science
Agency here, and they are also
affiliated to CSIR in some way.
In every branch I go,
I actually see them--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So it's kind of adding
one of the main groups.
It incorporates many
research groups.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It sounds like it's
based in multiple
locations, similar to AIMS.
YABEBAL FANTAYE: Because there
is one in Cape Town I know.
JESSICA PHALAFALA:
And Pretoria as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, what
about some of the smaller
affiliated groups
that you work with?
What are some of the
examples of those
that are-- they might not be
located in multiple locations,
but they do specific
and very deep research?
I know you've talked a little
bit about some of them.
YABEBAL FANTAYE: Yeah, there
are many such initiatives.
For example, I came
out from the program
called the National
Astrophysics and Space Science--
NASS-- the National Astrophysics
and Space Science program.
And when I came to do
my honors and master's
through that program, it has
trained in the space science
and astrophysics sector a lot.
I would say it has
really influenced it--
the landscape in Africa--
in terms of like,
graduate now, you'd
find also graduates from
many countries in that field.
And that is a
collaboration I gained
between almost every
university in South Africa.
So it's like we
were collaborating
with [INAUDIBLE] Observatory,
the observatory in Cape Town,
satellites, all
this collaboration.
But every university, for
example, in the Western Cape,
they have very strong
cosmology group.
They are doing
research, and they
are one of the main
science drivers
now in terms of research,
I would say, for the SK.
They have lots of
stuff doing in SK.
And as I said, in Wits,
UCT has many groups.
The cosmology group at UCT
was the strongest at the time.
I don't know now.
But it's like they had the
string theory, the cosmology,
which was led by
George Ellis, who
was a very prominent
cosmologist, who worked also
with other very prominent
scientists in the field.
So there are a lot--
the astronomy
department, if you go,
they have research,
big research group.
Even those that I'm aware
that I've given a talk
there, or I have
worked with people,
there are a lot of
research groups.
MELANIE WARRICK: I want to touch
on this-- so we're recording
this, and I didn't start out the
conversation with this point,
but we are recording this
at Deep Learning Indaba.
I've been emphasizing
that a lot when I
talk about this on our podcast.
We just were actually, before
we recorded this at a session,
where we were listening
to a couple of people talk
about democratizing
AI in Africa.
One of the points that
Nandu de Freitas made
was that we need to have
AI academic conferences,
like, in Africa, like
a large one, that's
established here.
And from everything
you're telling me,
there's significant
amount of research.
Now, we haven't
touched specifically
around the data science
in the AI space,
but there is a significant
amount of research
that's going on.
What are your thoughts
on his perspective?
JESSICA PHALAFALA: I
definitely agree with him.
I have to agree with him.
Especially as someone who's
just moved into data science,
I see the importance
of events like this.
Research can sometimes
be an isolating thing
to do and to take on.
But when you are brought
into a space like this one,
you get an opportunity to
really put your ideas out
there and have people
share their opinions
and give you feedback.
And I think feedback is
really important, especially
in a field that is still
developing at the rate
that data science and machine
learning is developing.
You really want to be
in a space where you're
producing work that's relevant.
And you only know if
your work is relevant
if you interact with
other people in that area.
So this is really something I
wish would take place, just not
the Deep Learning Indaba.
I wish there would be more
conferences of this nature.
Yeah, really, it's
an opportunity
to put your name out
there as a researcher,
it's an opportunity to
interact with others.
It's an opportunity
to get feedback,
to collaborate with others.
And we need to be at a stage
where we can collaborate
across countries in Africa.
And I think this
is the best place
to meet those people
in other countries that
are working on something similar
to what you're working on.
YABEBAL FANTAYE:
Yeah, I think it's--
to add on that, also--
I think it's the
most important aspect
is that usually these
are signs that people
are taking it serious and
people are paying attention.
Governments then would respond
to it and policies would--
so this is just like
a sign that also
shows you like, OK, people have
understood the significance.
And the bigger it
is, it also tells you
people are active in the field.
They're trying to work
on that and creating
that platform, basically.
I mean, I have seen
lots of research
came out from Sudan
and other places
where there are no
actual staff doing it,
but the students are interested.
And so therefore, they kind
of have this supervisor,
but who's also probably
not in the field,
but they go and do it,
the ones I observed.
It's such a nice, amazing
research, the idea is nice.
The other one that impressed
me was this Sudanese girl.
She showed me the
statistics like, OK,
there is depression in the
Arabic world-- many people die
out of suicide and depression.
MELANIE WARRICK: From the
mental health standpoint, yeah.
YABEBAL FANTAYE: Yes, in Sudan.
And so she thought,
oh, you know, why not?
Can we help them?
And then also, of course,
she showed me also
some of the statistics
she got from the,
I think, the UN
organization, where
it shows young people who
are depressed actually
go to social media
to say something
about their depression.
And so her idea was
like, oh, can we then
discover that early on such
that they can actually get help?
And of course, the
method that she implied,
she collected by hand,
because she said in Sudan,
many of the social
media are not working.
So she collected by
hand from Facebook.
You know, she went
to join the groups,
and then just collected this
data by hand, labeled by hand.
She got about 3,000
from Twitter and stuff.
Of course, there were some
flaws, and in her derivations,
but that's it.
The point is that she
has got everything,
but there was no one
probably to guide her,
so like all the
technical difficulties.
And coming here into the
Deep Learning Indaba,
and just me being
there, and at least
saying, like, OK, this
is an amazing thing,
but you have these sampling
issues, these things.
It just would give
her that insight,
and then she can
form collaborations.
So all these things
wouldn't have
happened if you don't have such
exposure in venues to present
your work, however small it is.
But putting your effort
out so that people
can then give you
the edge to just go
over and be what you can be.
And so I think this
Deep Learning Indaba,
and similarly there
is also Indaba-X,
but it's really a great start,
and there should be more.
And for me, there was a
depressing statistic recently
that came out from
McKinsey that it's
going to be this revolution.
AI revolution is going to
be changing the GDP as more
or less in the same
level as the one which
is the first
Industrial Revolution--
which we know, they affect.
It just created a massive shift.
But their simulation
shows that actually
Africa and other
developing countries
may not get the benefit.
Because already the landscape
has been so much shifted
to mostly US and China and other
countries which are already
strong.
So you really need some
kind of intervention
to make this prediction wrong.
Because we want to
be participating.
We want to benefit from it.
We want to change.
And other, like the WEF studies,
for example, the World Economic
Forum, they actually put the
food Industrial Revolution
to be maximal--
Africa to be maximally
benefiting from those.
So there are these
predictions where Africa
has all the challenges that
can be addressed, most of them
can be addressed through
systematization, resource
management, and all that.
And at the same
time, here you have
the economic, the GDP thing.
So if you match them, there is--
if these platforms are becoming
more and more--
I definitely think those
simulations can be wrong.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What do you think
could be done, from a research
institution standpoint,
to help this GDP issue?
The fact that there is this
expectation that you're already
behind the times, I guess?
JESSICA PHALAFALA:
I think what is
important is for us to focus
on African problems in terms
of research and not try and
produce research that is not
related to solving
African problems--
whether it be the drought
in Cape Town, et cetera.
That would keep our research
relevant to the African climate
and also allow the results of
our research to benefit us.
And maybe that's when we will
see the developments in AI
also benefit our GDP,
and maybe as a country,
as African states.
Another thing I think
is research institutes
need to do their very best
to keep their students
and not lose them
to universities
in North America, and
the UK, and Europe,
as the case has
been for many years.
This causes us to fall
behind, in terms of research.
This also causes us to not have
ownership of African research.
For me, these are
the kind of things
that are hindering the
progress with respect
to research in AI and
machine learning--
holding on to researchers
and also working
on African problems.
YABEBAL FANTAYE: I think
another aspect, which
I would say, for
example, another research
that I was really greatly
enjoyed in the post-doc session
was Jessica's, who
was working actually
on the foundations
of Deep Learning.
I believe that it's just
not only you have to--
and you have to
build the confidence,
not just only to do
something, but also
to follow your curiosity.
So I think what they are doing,
for example, in this Manifold
Learning, trying to find,
ascertain aspects, such
that they can then
improve and understand
how the actual black box--
JESSICA PHALAFALA: The
mathematical foundations of--
YABEBAL FANTAYE: Yes,
how the black box
is working, and trying to
then get the-- so competing
at global, at the cutting edge.
And that's also, you need
that kind of confidence
and you need to build it.
Because without that
confidence, it's
basically going
to be like, we're
just going to happy
to be sitting nearby
in somebody, right?
And I think that mentality-- and
that's why I really like also
Neil Turkos' way of
thinking sometimes,
and why there is the Quantum
Leap Africa Institute, which
we just started recently.
And the whole idea is
like, yeah, let's be bold.
Because in this
world, as I think
they say it again
and again, it's
only for those who
really can dream big
and just are not afraid--
MELANIE WARRICK:
And take the risks.
YABEBAL FANTAYE: So that is
like in the Quantum, we know--
right now, it's still the game
is not decided in data science
and in AI.
We have a lot to contribute.
But we also have to plan the
future, to lead, for example,
some of the expected
innovations or revolutions
that may be coming
with quantum computing.
So the Quantum Leap
Africa is like,
OK, let's gear our
mind that we will
be the leaders in that field.
Right now we have data science.
Let's build-- because it
requires the computer.
The quantum machine
will require algorithms,
will require sensors, and stuff.
Let's build to what
we have now to that.
Let's have all the expertise.
Let's not be worrying about
whether it's this or that.
It's like, let's
build our confidence.
Let's have that
kind of ambition.
Because it's only the ambition.
And I think I can
share so many times
that the people in West Africa,
when they play football,
it is their ambition
that drives them--
that makes them play in Europe.
And people in Kenya and in
East Africa, in general,
when they run--
which is just also
partially-- it influences me.
I just think about winning.
I just even don't think about--
that confidence was
built by few people
who broke just stats,
that kind of sphere where
it was blocking.
And suddenly someone
just got gold,
or they were just
the best players,
and then people were
like, it was me.
I can relate my life.
There was nothing special.
And so it was just you
build that confidence.
And so all these
ambitious projects,
as well as I am also leading
the community of scientists
in Africa, which incorporates
the Next Einstein Fellows,
and Next Einstein Ambassadors
from all over Africa,
and we are trying
also exactly to do
like, we are doing
something, we are
close to the research
and the knowledge.
And the politicians are
very close to the decisions
they have to do every day.
It's a hard job.
The business people have to
deal and they have to survive.
So that dialogue we can form.
Because we have
the time to think,
and we have the time to reflect.
We are easy to the data.
We can analyze and
get the insights.
And then we have
to share that one.
So we have in this
policy advising--
so we have objectives
to try to be advising AU
in some, because these fellows
and ambassadors are working
on every field, from medical
to climate to economics
to computer science,
data science.
So it's everywhere.
We have all those fields.
And we are increasing--
we are not just
fellow or an ambassador.
It's all about let's
build the community,
and let this community
contribute in all forms.
Just let it not to be doormat--
the whole point is,
let us not be passive.
And in this transformation, all
the work, the fundamental work,
the pure mathematician,
has a lot to contribute,
as well as the one
who is doing just
basically in the clinical
testing in some remote places.
So there is a lot more to do.
So I think those
would, I would say,
contribute in making
sure if we keep
doing them in the right way.
I think it will make these
predictions wrong, I would say.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And I noticed when
I've been talking to
people at the conference
that there is a common fear
that I don't know enough.
I'm afraid to jump in.
But yet I'm here
because I'm interested.
And I'm bringing
this up because I've
talked to a lot of people
who are in this space,
or who want to be in this
space, in many locations--
I've been very lucky
in that regard,
to be able to talk
to so many people who
are trying to get into AI
from all over the world.
And there's that common fear
and common intimidation--
it's everywhere.
And it's here.
And I've heard people talking
about this here, as well.
So you're talking
about the confidence.
I think that the
question becomes
how to encourage people who
don't feel like they know.
I think that's
also the key, too--
don't feel like they know
enough, and they're afraid.
How to encourage them.
And what do you
think could be done
to help make sure that
the barriers to entry
don't feel as intimidating?
JESSICA PHALAFALA:
Firstly, I think
one of your first
questions was, why
do people feel intimidated
by this area of study?
And I think from what
I've seen thus far
is that machine
learning or data science
is a multidisciplinary area.
And I think that's the
intimidating part--
that mathematics
alone is not enough.
It's a combination of
statistics, mathematics,
and computer science.
And that requires--
if you're coming
from any of those
angles, you're going
to be required to broaden your
knowledge on the other topics.
So I think that's
the first thing.
And I don't think
it's something that
should be seen as a barrier,
because the support is there--
especially in universities.
Especially because this
is an upcoming field.
So supervisors, institutes,
are aware that people
who are doing
research in this area
require a little bit more
support in that regard.
I think conferences
such as this one
do help provide you
with that confidence,
like Yabebal was saying.
I'm working on a
problem, and being
able to present to
my peers, and present
to people who are more
experienced in this field, also
allows me to gain
more knowledge,
and allows them to also nudge
me in the right direction,
provide me with the
resources that I need.
So these kind of
conferences are really--
it's really important to have
these kind of engagements,
where when you
present, someone might
be a little bit more
experienced in that field,
and you're stuck
on something that,
for them, is just a quick,
hey, here's a resource.
Once you've taken
a look at this,
it will push you in
the right direction.
Or hey, here's my email
address, let's meet up
and we'll take this further.
So I think that's a
good starting point.
There are many other
things that can be done.
But this, for me, is, in the
year that I've been studying,
this has been one of those
moments where I've learned
so much in a period
of four days--
it hasn't even come
to an end yet--
I think that that really
does get the job done.
YABEBAL FANTAYE:
Just to add on that,
I think she said most
of the things also
I would have liked to say in
terms of this kind of platforms
definitely put you
in that context.
The people who are doing great
out there and the differences
are not that big as you think.
And so it just gives you
the proof to yourself
to check that you are
in the right direction,
or this is the things you miss,
or the things you thought--
it's big, it's not big.
It gives you the laboratory
to check for yourself.
And usually those, I
believe, are the only way
that you will get confidence.
So another aspect that I am
working on that, because that's
for me the most important
thing that happened to my life,
so I relate directly
to it, is that
because, you could be planning--
I was ambitious.
Abebe Bikila for me was
like, yeah, what did he do?
Abebe Bikila is one of
the runners in Ethiopia
who got the first Olympic
gold medal in the 1960s--
he was the first African
to actually do that.
And it inspired a generation
of runners from then on.
And there were a
couple of things
he did, which I don't know
how that relates, that fits,
but for me, I like
the narratives
because it really helps me.
He was running
barefoot, and he was
training in Ethiopia barefoot.
And he went to Japan
in the Tokyo marathon,
then he was given
a shoe to run to.
And he had to decide--
that's my narration,
I like to put it--
and he had to decide
to run on this thing
that he hasn't got used
to, everyone is doing it.
Or just do his way,
the way he knows.
And I think, for me, the
most spectacular event
was he decided to just run
barefoot-- just his own way.
And then, he ran, just
completely made history.
So I think one thing I
draw from that experience,
and the same can
be said, I think,
in the Western Africa
for the football,
probably, is people,
to achieve greatness,
they didn't just
have to pretend--
they had to do their own way.
And they had to be
taking the consequences.
So for us, I took that
inspiration for me,
and we have this
project which is,
I would say, a significant
fraction of my three years,
in the last three years I
spent thinking about it,
because that's
what's important--
checking every detail and
how you moved in this space.
And what we do that
it's actually--
it's influenced whom you
knew when you were a child.
Did you know a mathematician?
And if not, when you
become a mathematician,
you won't be confident, because
you feel like you may not
understanding it the right way.
If you didn't know a physicist,
when you got into physics,
you're not sure.
But it just seems
so naturally so nice
is that, even just one handshake
when you were probably four
years old, with a
physicist, could
have changed that thing a lot.
Because then, that
propagates in time--
like when you talk
with your peers,
you probably would say,
yeah, I know a mathematician,
they do this.
But then you think, every
time you say those statements,
you're actually thinking.
So it just doesn't even
need sometimes maybe a lot,
it just needs people
everywhere in remote areas,
they need to see the real people
doing that sort of modeling.
So what we are doing, we have
this project which is really,
as I said, the significant
part of my thinking
in the last three
years spent on that,
is that we have
Astrobus Ethiopia.
So what we do is that
we're taking the bus,
we get all the people--
and we don't distinguish,
because abstraction
and composition is an
idea, you abstract it,
and then use those
abstracts to compose.
That is mathematics,
that is physics,
that is art, that is fashion
design, that is painting,
that poem, that is everything.
You get to some
abstract level, you
use that abstract level to
create some symphony-- just
like music.
Notes to symphonies.
And so we take that one.
So we bring everyone--
all those people
who believed in it,
but who are also doing things,
like real fashion designers,
if it's scientists.
Scientists really have
that ambition and to do.
Inventors-- so we have art,
science, and innovation.
We put together,
we put in the bus,
and we just drive across
the whole country.
And we just get
off, and what we do
is mostly not teaching--
it's not about teaching.
It's about belongingness-- you
belong to me, I belong to you.
We are in the same family.
So when you know me, and when
you see me now in the TV,
you say, I know that guy--
I met him.
And that confidence, we
take that inspiration,
and we are doing it, and we
are trying to expand it also
in other parts.
We wanted, for
example, in Rwanda--
I want Rwandese to do it.
In Senegal, I want the
Senegalese to do it.
Because that relation cuts
that barrier which like,
you may have a
different opportunity.
So in Ethiopia, we want
to do it with Ethiopians.
We're doing in IBM.
We're doing it in
Silicon Valley.
We're doing research in
cosmology and fashion design--
we want them to be
there and just shake,
because then the kids don't
have any more reasoning
to say they are different.
Because they are them.
MELANIE WARRICK: I love the fact
that there are many people here
who have come to this conference
who are very much junior, very
much just entering this space,
who have taken the risk,
have overcome
their intimidation.
And also, I've seen so many
people who welcomed them in,
and been very inclusive.
And that's been
really impressive.
Before we wrap up, I just want
to touch on a couple of things.
Any other things
that you've seen
that you were really excited
about by this conference,
that you wanted to touch on?
That you wanted to mention?
YABEBAL FANTAYE: I think
there are, as I say,
I mentioned some of them.
I really was-- even if Jessica
is at AIMS, and we talked,
and I know her supervisor--
it was very good to see
what they are doing.
And so I went to
her poster, and I
asked her to tell me in
detail what's going on.
So it was really impressive to
see that confidence of really
working on just the foundation
of deep learning, especially
this black box that we
still don't understand.
Trying to find--
and there method
is different, and
clever, and I am not
qualified to say anything.
But it's really impressive that
people are thinking and pushing
in the boundary-- not only
just in the application side,
but also just in
the pure math side.
And another aspect is just those
people, that is one example,
but I have seen other people
doing really clever, but more
concerned from their own
they think is a problem.
So then they're trying to
use the methods available,
and trying to improve life.
So I think those are
the moments I was
very much happy that I am here.
And even if I am not a
big believer in this big--
big conferences are
like we draw ourselves,
and we just look and we meet.
Networking is the biggest thing
for me in these kind of things.
And as I say, me
talking to that person,
the other person talking, and
just guiding here and there
and other person guiding
me on the problems
they have-- so these
things are what I really
value from big conferences,
not the content would change.
So I think, yeah,
those are the kind
of moments that makes me feel
like, yeah, we need to do more.
I think this has to be
not just one Indaba,
there should be
more in such a way
that because for such a billion
population, and the huge size,
one conference is not just--
so definitely, as Nando
was saying, is just,
really, we need to
increase, and we
have to bring also the
global competitors such
that they can see this
talent, such that there
is fair collaboration,
that people
could do here something amazing
that could be highlighted.
Maybe not only just
change the lives
of people in Africa, but also
in the lives in the world.
Because we have a lot
of different insights.
And I think that's what's
also Neil Turok believes
is that if we really have
the chance to really grow,
it's because we see
problems differently.
That's our gift.
So we can't compete
with that thing--
that's our real resource.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
OK, and Jessica, what about you?
JESSICA PHALAFALA: Yeah, maybe
I can just say three things.
One of the first things
is the coding lab
sessions have been very useful.
I think for those, like you
said, who are new in the field,
it gives you exposure
to the different topics
across from CNNs, RNNs, to
just deep, feed-forward models.
It just gives you that
exposure you need.
So if you're still
in the process
of identifying your problem
and developing your problem.
Secondly, for those who are more
established in the industry,
I think it's also great
for them to just see
what students are getting
up to, and other researchers
are getting up to.
I think it's been a great
time for students to also make
new relationships,
and I know a couple
of people who actually
found co-supervisors
during the conference,
which is great.
And some who have identified
potential supervisors.
So that's just wonderful.
And then within the
students, as well, we
are coming up with ideas of how
to bring small-scale Indabas
into the rural areas,
going back to, like I said,
I was born in Polokwane.
And this is something of
great interest in a part
of a foundation
called [NON-ENGLISH]..
And we do this at a low scale.
So something like
this motivates us
and gives us inspiration of how
to change the current method
that we are using when we
go back into community.
In one week, this conference
is able to achieve so much.
So this is a time for us to
also be inspired, as students,
who want to give back
to the community on what
is the best way to do so?
To learn from the best.
How to run a lab session,
because in the rural areas,
there aren't a lot
of laboratories.
In fact, the rural
areas that I've been to,
students are not
exposed to computers.
So it teaches how to efficiently
give back to the community.
If this conference can
do this in one week,
it's inspiring us to go
back into the community-- it
can take one week to also
change students' lives
and give them that
representation
that he was talking about.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
All right, last
question for you both.
In a couple words,
can you tell me
if there's any key
resources that you
recommend based on what
your experience has been?
And anything else
that I might not
have covered that you
wanted to make sure you
touched on before we wrap up.
Jessica, why don't
I start with you?
JESSICA PHALAFALA:
OK, and one thing
that's been very useful
for me is Coursera.
If you are someone who's
moving from pure mathematics,
or pure statistical
background, I
think Coursera is a
great place to start,
because you really get to
learn in your private space,
and there are no limitations
to your learning.
I went through a
number of courses--
some are 11 weeks, you can
really cut down that time
if you're really focused.
And they will give
you exposure to--
like the machine-learning
course just
gives you exposure to an
array of different algorithms.
So if you're new to the field,
Coursera, go onto the website,
explore the different
options that are available.
And it will just give
you far more exposure
than maybe a semester
course would.
So definitely that.
And yeah, and
obviously, just always
go through papers in the
fields that most interests you.
That's a good starting point.
That's always a
good starting point.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
YABEBAL FANTAYE: Yeah, I
think that I would say,
I think those are
great resources.
And there are many
online courses
that are very, very,
very good, that people
don't have an excuse.
Main issue could be language,
and that's, I think,
what's the Google AI in
Ghana and others are trying
to-- and IBM, they
are also working--
so they're trying to fill
that gap between people
who don't understand.
But another, I think, if I just
mention one other resource,
the [INAUDIBLE]
page, which is very
good in sometimes bringing some
complicated concepts in a very
easy way.
So I think those are--
I think I would put
those links there.
And yeah--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Those are great ones.
And last words of advice
being, take risks?
YABEBAL FANTAYE:
Yes, I think we need
to go in the direction that
hasn't been tried before.
MELANIE WARRICK: I like that.
YABEBAL FANTAYE:
Because otherwise, we
know the ones that work, so--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Try new directions.
JESSICA PHALAFALA:
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you, both of you,
very much for joining me today.
I really appreciate it.
YABEBAL FANTAYE:
Thank you so much.
JESSICA PHALAFALA:
Thank you, Melanie,
thank you for having us.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you again,
Yabebal and Jessica for
coming on to the podcast,
and sharing your insights
around AI research
that you're doing in the
area, and other groups,
and what's going on.
So we appreciate you
coming on the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
thank you very much.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark, if
I'm using the cluster auto
scaler for Kubernetes
or GKE, how
can I prevent it from removing
specific nodes from the cluster
when scaling down?
MARK MANDEL: So, cluster
auto-scaler for Kubernetes
is something I've been
digging into lately.
It's actually really
cool technology
in that, what it does is that
as you create more and more pods
through essentially any
mechanism, deployments
or other such things, if
it finds that there isn't
enough room for those pods
to exist, it will add nodes
up into a specified
limit that you add.
So it'll be like, oh,
you've now got 1,000,
so let's make sure
there's room for that.
And it'll add nodes
in a timely manner.
And vise versa if you were
like, oh, I only need now 100,
or I had 1,000, it will
scale it back down again.
All very cool.
But there are some
scenarios where
you might want to be like,
don't remove that node.
Right now it's fairly
arbitrary, in terms
of what it removes--
it just makes sure
that there's still room
for things you need,
and things like that.
It will kill empty ones.
But there is actually some
control that the cluster
auto-scaler gives you, as well,
if there's particular nodes,
maybe you're running
a daemon set on,
or you have specific hardware
on a particular thing
you want to make sure it
doesn't get brought down.
And there's a couple
of interesting ways
you can do this-- and I think
this is actually really cool.
So at the node level, there
is an annotation you can add,
basically a scaled
down disabled is true.
So if you add that
to a particular node,
it's just going to go, nope,
I'm not going to touch that one.
It's fine.
I don't care.
But the other thing
worth noting is sometimes
you might not know what
node you want to prevent
being able to get rid of.
What you actually may also
want to be able to do is say,
hey, if there is this
particular pod running
on a particular node,
don't kill that node.
And so you can
actually do that too--
I didn't realize this
up until recently,
and I thought this
was really cool.
If you add the annotation,
save to evict false on the pod,
whatever node that is on,
the cluster or the scaler
will not remove that.
Which is also cool, too.
There's a bunch of other
restrictions, as well.
We'll link to the FAQ
in the show notes.
It'll talk things about stuff
about pod disruption budgets
and a few other things.
But I thought it was also just
really nice that the cluster
auto-scaler gave you
that kind of control,
both at the node level,
and at a pod level,
to be able to control what
it does when it scales down.
Because usually, scaling down,
that's the trickier problem.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Thanks for that insight.
OK, Mark, where are you
going to be next week?
MARK MANDEL: Where am I
MELANIE WARRICK: Where are
you going to be this month?
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: This
month, I may be--
I still need to make
a decision on that,
I'll see what's happening
there in October.
But I know you said
this month, but I'm
really excited cause I'm
going to my first KubeCon
in December, and I got
accepted as a speaker.
So I'm really excited to
see a whole bunch of people
at KubeCon.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Good, that's awesome.
MARK MANDEL: What are you up to?
MELANIE WARRICK: I am going
to be speaking this week
at Monktoberfest over in Maine.
And then I will be
at CAMLIS, which
is a security, data conference.
It's in Washington,
DC, the following week.
That's the plan.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Melanie, thank you
so much for joining me
for yet another podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]